hey Siri I'm home palm sweet home this
is home pot with an a8 chip six
microphone arrays high excursion woofer
seven tweeter array home pod is more
than just a speaker Siri to have any new
messages you have a new message from
post mates
hey it's post mates I'm on the way with
your food would you like to reply yes
what do you want to say thanks can't
wait for my meal your reply to post mate
says things can't wait for my meal ready
to send it yes I'll send your message
hey Siri turn on my teapot okay this
thing is so fast it's actually shocking
hey Siri turn off my teapot okay she'll
not only read write and send your
messages but she can control your entire
home from lighting security garage doors
thermostats even outlets basically
anything but as home can enabled well
the teapots pretty cool but one of the
things that Apple is most known for is
revolutionising music the way that we
buy it the way that we listen to it the
way to be experience it and they're
doing it here again with a home pod you
guys might remember back in January of
2001 at Macworld is when they first
introduced iTunes we're gonna change all
this today with something we call iTunes
and then a few months later they
introduced and we were introducing a
product today it takes us exactly there
and that product is called iPod iMac
iBook iPod hold on wait a minute
dramatic reveal this this is the
original iPod and this was released hey
Siri how long ago was October 23rd 2001
it was 16 years ago 16 years ago it's
actually kind of crazy to just hear her
say that I mean I knew how long ago it
was but to really just hear her say that
that really reiterated the fact that I'm
getting hold
this is the home pod my sweet boy would
you like it oh this is our theme song
honey you can also control home pod with
touch one tap to pause double tap to
play the next track and triple tap to
play the previous track instead of
saying hey Siri you can just press and
hold to activate her and you can adjust
the volume by pressing the plus or the
minus or they say hey Siri turn the
volume all the way up that's very loud
are you sure yes I'm all about that
yes but what's crazy is there's a six or
a microphone surrounding this entire
home pod so this thing can hear me from
very far distances hey Siri do you love
me do you love me would you like me to
search the web or what I was skeptical
when they first announced the home pod
but now after using it and experiencing
it it's pretty amazing if it's placed in
the middle of an open room it'll give
consistent 360 audio throughout so no
matter where you are in the room it'll
have the same perfect sound the
microphones listen to the reflection of
the sound off of the surrounding
surfaces so even if it's next to a wall
it'll adjust appropriately for its new
environment to make sure you're getting
the best sound quality possible I really
want to demo this for you guys so you
can actually hear it but it's gonna be
really difficult because you can't hear
what I'm hearing in real life you guys
are on headphones you're on your
computers but I'm gonna do my best to
give you a little demonstration just
know that this thing sounds amazing hey
Siri play me some Lindsey Stirling sure
here's a personalized station of Lindsey
Stirling my friend this is my friend
she's on my home pod right now hey Siri
who's the song bye this is Lindsey
Stirling with the track Mirror house hey
Siri text Lindsey Stirling and tell her
that I love her your message to Lindsey
Stirling says
I love her ready to send it no I think
Lindsay might have been a little bit
confused getting a message for me that
says I love her anyway
hey Siri play me some imagine dragons
alright let's hear imagine dragons hey
Siri play another song with this album
playing believer by imagine dragging off
of this one hey Siri skip forward thirty
Seconds hey Siri I forgot what I wanted
to tell you hey Siri who's the drummer
of imagine dragons Dan Reynolds and
Daniel Platts Minh played drums and
imagine dragons my mech Pro just arrived
while we were shooting this video and we
captured it all on film and I actually
started crying oh my god
I've been waiting a really long time for
this okay I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
push it in look are you able to focus on
these years I'm not this good of an
actress
this is real emotion oh my gosh I can't
believe it it's here early look hey Siri
a place of music for doing yoga hey Siri
find me a yoga studio in Sherman Oaks
one option is core power yoga about
seven point eight miles to your north as
the crow flies on Ventura Boulevard in
Los Angeles which averages four and a
half stars according to Yelp hey Siri is
there any traffic to Sherman Oaks right
now traffic to Sherman Oaks Los Angeles
is light so I'm estimating 22 minutes by
405 North hey Siri add to my really good
video ideas list to make a home pod cake
okay I added video ideas list to make a
home pocket to the reminders hey Siri
let's go play some video games okay
let's see your video games by Lana Del
Rey huh not exactly what I said but okay
[Music]
hey Siri turn on my lights hey Siri text
my sister and ask her why she's not
playing call of duty with me right now
okay I'm slurring my speech I apologize
I'm getting real amped about this game
hey Siri stop playing so one of the
things that I do like about the home pod
is you can actually use it as
speakerphone so I'm gonna call my sister
because she's clearly ignoring my text
messages right now which is very
upsetting hold on Jenna hello hello hi
it's you Jenna II hey do you want to hop
on call of duty why are you ignoring my
text messages alright well I guess I'm
gonna go back to playing then
it's not only I'm able to airplay my
speaker phone calls but I can also
airplay from Apple TV so my Apple TV's
up there I get airplay what I'm watching
here to the home pot now it's not
available yet but you will later this
year with a software update be able to
get to home pods and use them in stereo
depending upon what voice you have set
for your Siri home pod we'll take on
that voice for example here's the
Australian male is the podcast what does
this all mean also not available at
launch but really cool with airplay to
you'll be able to put a home pod pretty
much in any room any corner of the house
and you can control her by rooms so for
example we're upstairs hey Siri play
heavy metal upstairs now playing metal
radio
hey serious stop playing and if you have
one in the kitchen you can tell it'll
play 90s rock in the kitchen or played
something else in the living room but
you can also sync them all up and play
one single thing throughout the whole
house
play some Slayer all right that's your
Slayer please be ready hey Siri turn the
volume to 20% look she can still hear me
over her loudness hey Siri play raining
blood yes you guys might not know but I
listen to heavy metal a lot in high
school hey Siri when was the song
released granny blood by Slayer came out
on October 7th 1986 1986 okay I was most
two so I wasn't listen you just play her
when I was 2 hey Siri stop playing how
got such a hit well thank you guys so
much for watching I have so far been
enjoying the home pod a lot more than I
really thought I was going to I have
ordered a few more so I will give you
guys a full update maybe you know you
know how I roll a week with home pod
video I'm gonna keep playing some Call
of Duty and I will see you guys later I
also did an unboxing video so if you
want to check that out I'll put a link
in the description and an end card here
and if that's that same with the video I
will see you guys on the battlefield
[Music]
they attend his lectures upside down oh
no it's okay it's not a big deal
bake a home pod cake if you have one in
the kitchen you can say play jazz in the
kitchen or I don't like jazz what am I
talking about it's not that I don't like
jazz if you like jazz that's just not
something I listen to or maybe I should
start oh my god sir how many days is
5,400 didn't so I forgot what you said
already so days ago oh she just told me
what I really couldn't say hmm you know
what me either could say hey Siri let's
get the sparked I started
good right now why am I on why bro can
you pick up a cake tomorrow now it was
for the video it's okay alright bye
she's never sure if like I'm actually
filming a video or if it's a real life
question anyway
[Music]